bonjour et merci être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
secteur de la restauration semble voir
le bout du tunnel avec une possible
réouverture du moins des terrasses déjà
d'ici la mi mai comment est ce que vous
avez commencé à vous organiser justement
pour se dé confinement écoutez donc
commence à être habitué des premières
séances de ses espérances donc espoir
d'ouvrir le 15 mai mais bon pourquoi pas
et tous les terrasses on espère d'ouvrir
dans des conditions tout à fait normales
ces pouvoirs des terrasses avec des
tables d'ahmed deux de chaque côté
je pense qu'on va être dans une mission
impossible parce que paris est la fille
dentelle et est prêt à se jeter sur les
terrasses mais bon on a d'espoir tout
est une question d'organisation de
livraison et c'est maintenant
aujourd'hui 10 aux économies pour nous
c'est la question essentielle c'est sait
comment ça va se passer avec notre mini
dont le maire est le fond sonorités va
continuer juin juillet août pour avoir
une ouverture souvent un tel chiffre
d'affaires de 50 % de moins à paris on
va dire peut-être qu'on province ils ont
agi d'affaires plus élevé par rapport
aux vacances je peux j'espère pour eux
mais si on veut éviter un chaos
économique de notre mieux la brasserie
restaurant
il faut vraiment que ce fonctionnalités
continue pendant trois quatre mois
pendant d'ouverture entre romance avec
un chaos économique pour tous les
restaurants les brasseries et les autres
ça doit être assez difficile de se
projeter après une si longue période 100
son client j'aimerais que l'on revienne
à c'était sud qui a été dévoilé par les
échos qui parle de 100 mille salariés
qui pourrait ne pas revenir retrouver
leur poste dans la restauration est ce
que vous avez vous constaté cette perte
de motivation chez certains salariés
nous dans notre bouquet à peu près on a
un peu plus de 300 salariés et au jour
d'aujourd'hui on en a une trentaine qui
ont déjà changé de direction
évidemment il faut comprendre le sait
jean françois sont nous avons des
horaires
très long de 7 heures à 2 heures du
matin ils ont découvert une nouvelle vie
et il ya eu des gens des salariés de 30
m pour décourager qui sont dirigés dans
d'autres métiers que j'admire parce que
ne se sont pas laissé abattre et je
trouve ça très admiratif
maintenant vous savez qu'on va ouvrir je
suis assez confiante justement on aura
des nouveaux salariés de nouveaux gènes
qu'on pourra prendre en formation il
faut et on va s'adapter c'est pas la
chose la plus importante à mes yeux la
plonge la chose la plus importante à mes
yeux je répète c'est ce fonds soda et et
qui doit continuer pour aider les
restaurateurs à se sortir de ce marasme
où il faut jamais oublier que ce
gouvernement est fermé nos
établissements et est vraiment avec un
ministre de la santé comme véran où il
faut quand même pas oublier tout ce
désastre des masses pas des masses
l'étape à l'établé se laver les mains
aujourd'hui je vous donne un exemple
dans les médias vous êtes toujours en
train de parler des vaccins aujourd'hui
on parle plus du tout de se nettoyer les
mains blood
donc tout ça est un petit peu
extrêmement floue mais nous l'économie
avait pas foule où aller ses deux plus
deux gars qu'un donc aujourd'hui on va
ouvrir les prêts bancaires c'est très
important si vous devez présenter
alentours des services devant que ce
soit la banque populaire label pénalise
pas les prêts ont redémarré au mois
d'avril pour tous les français
restaurateur bancaire de 10000 euros par
mois le prix est aujourd'hui des banques
font complètement à l'ouest sauf la
caisse d'epargne da qui viennent de
s'accorder leur étalement des prévôts
trois mois et aujourd'hui la bei pélabon
populaire et d'alcool ils sont
complètement noyée se perdent jamais
obligés eux qui est un soutien
économique pour payer les fournisseurs
les loyers des bureaux mais pas pour
payer les crédits bancaires vous
imaginez un peu ce délire voilà donc on
est on espère pour nous le maire va
donner un gros coup de pouce aux
beaucoup plus tôt un gros coup de poing
au service bancaire aux dires de décaler
les près de trois mois pour aider les
restaurateurs à ouvrir leurs
établissements plus sereinement
donc aujourd'hui c'est pas la crainte de
ne pas avoir des clients puisque je sens
on le sait les français sont impatients
de se retrouver à nouveau voilà sur les
terrasses de café dans les restaurants
mais c'est surtout cet accompagnement
conomique que vous espérez donc pour au
moins les premiers mois de la reprise
exactement exactement aurez bien compris
qu'on allait ouvrir d'avoir des
extérieurs à paris et en france vous
avez 50 % d'établissement compas des
terrasses où ils vont faire ces gens là
qui vont rester en place apparaît
justement là anne hidalgo avait avait
annoncé que le dispositif d des
terrasses sur les trottoirs parisiens
allaient rester au moins cet été
aujourd'hui avec debout elle dit
jusqu'au 30 juin pour l'instant on est
dans le silence total
est ce des terrains ces dernières vont
être prolongées ce que je l'espère
évidemment pour aider tous les
restaurateurs au moins tout l'été mais
maintenant je n'ai pas de confirmation
de la mairie paris xi s'est prolongée
jusqu'au 30 septembre au 30 octobre jeu
c'est le silence total
en tout cas merci beaucoup pascal ranger
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce matin
je rappelle que vous êtes propriétaires
et actionnaires de plusieurs brasseries
parisiennes